Here's the tail of a language.
They can build impressively long words
and why it ended up alone in Europe,
surrounded by languages
that work so differently.
Central Europe,
a patchwork of nations with Jagat borders.
Let me switch to a language map though.
What do you see and probably
still patches, a patch of German,
a romance language, some Slavic
languages and this patch here, Hungarian.
Now look again at this map of language
families that Hungarian patch is a
language island surrounded on
all sides by Indo Europeans.
After I learned about this isolation and
then calculated out how long Hungarian
words are,
I just had to try out on my young yet
the Hungarian language for myself.
I am not Hungarian though.
Practice along, and correct me,
but this tail is too good not to share.
Go back 1,122 years to a time when the
Carpathian basin flat landlocked in
surrounded by mountains was being
squabbled over and who better to settle
squabbles then tribes of nomadic horseman
known to Europeans as angry but to
themselves by the name of their foremost
tribe. Modular led by Arthropod,
the modulars conquered the basin in
the homeland, taking of eight 94, uh,
homeful Galosh yes,
lush s is shut and this is how you write
an s but don't flip it or you get a
judge on Darien for decades after
these masters of the bow in the stirrup
consolidated,
their rule drove a wedge between South
Slavic and the rest of Slavic and rattled
nerves all the way to Italy,
France and Spain.
It said they even had westerners
on their knees praying.
They see these women got older,
me better knows Domina
arthropods descendants did
manage to settle in warm up to
the west,
right at the turn of the Millennium,
Stephen the first established
a European kingdom,
a surprising bastion of Christendom,
but success left Hungarian isolated.
And by the end of this tale,
this language with it's oddly long words
will reveal just how alone Hungarian is
and is not. Do you remember
my longest word, adventure?
Those languages stretched words by taking
a base word and compounding it with
another base. Like say you
have two towns, Buda and pest,
and you smash them together into one name.
But that's not the reason Hungarian
pops out. Long words left and right.
It's base words at a bunch
of grammatical slots,
mostly at the end slots for everything.
I swear the verb Yelland
means notifier report.
It's already itself built
from smaller pieces, but
whatever. Let's keep it simple.
Put a bay in front and the action
goes inwards or into Balent.
Add the reflexive Kazic and your reporting
yourself into logging in while you're
at it. Chinks, this subject
to be Olympic Isaac.
Oh and don't forget slots for tenses and
moods like the conditional Ne Wood in
bail and cause nick nouns
have hoards of forms.
They put Latin to shame.
Take em,
but say you wanted to give
something to that human,
you'll need the date of case embedded
neck. If there are multiple humans,
they're embedded. And if there's
something for all of them embedded CONNEC.
Wow, look at all those intimidating
sounding cases down the list.
These are just forms for say,
up to being on top of going into,
going out of and so on.
Same for adjectives.
Knowledge is great, but let's step
this up a bit. Mazzetti great.
Like means wonderful using the
same endings. You can have plural,
wonderful things and save them
for a wonderful one. Note,
city neck or for many wonderful ones,
not city ethnic.
Whoa,
there's more.
How about a slot for comparing
wonderful things to find out which one's
wonderful.
Ular built city but and a superlative
prefix slot for the most wonderful of all.
Not City had.
Wait before you take a breath,
bringing her endings once more leg,
not city beck,
nick who now you see why
Hungarian words get so tough?
These clumps of roots and
affixes look glued together.
So linguist named this kind of word,
building a gluten nation
with the Latin root glue.
Some have grown skeptical of the concept,
but it's been resilient.
Part of the glue holding Hungarian
together is it's val harmony.
Did you happen to notice all the,
as those as in the suffix are
there to match the val in the base.
So the plural of Embeda is embedded,
but mouths are cyroc and
medic cyroc autonomic.
That's basic Hungarian grammar,
but it's so foreign to all its neighbors.
Why though? We know where it ended
up, but where did it come from?
The clue to its origins is
right there and it's words.
Historical linguists traced a trail of
related words back to languages akin to
Hungarian, nowhere near Hungary, way,
way,
way off in West Siberia.
Together with Hungarian,
these languages are part of
a broader urologic family.
Hungarians ancestors migrated
from Siberia out to the southwest,
bringing their long words to the doorstep
of the Carpathian basin where our
story started. See Hungarian in the
end, you're not completely alone.
You just have a long distance kind of
linguistic relationship set at like the
ticket ish. Him stick around
and subscribe for language.